too much eye contact affects
interviewing allowing the person to
drift off to be comfortable to be
reflective is often better than what you
see on television it's actually easier
to resist someone when they're in front
of you you know it's easier to fend
somebody off than somebody's next to you
somebody's next to you it's pretty tough
to argue with them it's like we're both
on the same side
joe navarro welcome to the show
good to be here chris
for the people who aren't familiar with
you and your background
where have you gone that's led you to
this point
not very far you know 25 years in the
fbi where i i got to play as a swat team
commander spy catcher and bureau pilot
uh i was the fbi's body language expert
and then i retired and wrote 14 books
and uh
so not much
yeah a uh colorful career path i think
you could say what's the what are those
different um elements within the bureau
there for the people that haven't got a
clue what you're talking about
yeah well you know within the fbi uh we
have a lot of sub programs so
uh i when i entered into the bureau i
was already a licensed pilot and we're
always in need of pilots because we use
uh
aircraft as platforms for surveillance
so i i got to do that and then
they they wanted volunteers which means
i was pushed into
going into the swat program because
you know sometimes you're up against
some uh
some pretty dastardly groups
and uh spent 14 years as a on a swat
team uh in puerto rico and then in tampa
and
and
doing counter-terrorism investigations
but mostly you know i spent
those 25 years so you can do other
things within the fbi
um i was uh part of the national
securities uh uh behavioral program
which uh looked at uh human behavior
and uh and actually that's really what
led me um
not only my spy catching but uh but led
me to uh to to begin to write books
and uh
and in fact the the the first book uh
that i wrote with uh jack schaefer
uh really was i was getting ready to
retire from the fbi and and people were
saying you know
there's all this knowledge that you have
but you're taking it with you uh why
don't you share it and uh i never i
never intended to to
be a writer
um
in fact i often say i'm i'm a writer i'm
or an author i'm really not a writer i
know what a good writer is
i'm sure you know the the the difference
but
um you know all all in all it's it's uh
it was a fantastic experience and um and
obviously you you learn a lot um you
know i got to work with uh
british intelligence i work i worked
with german intelligence
and just different folks around the
world and it
makes for an interesting uh career
what's the difference between swat in
puerto rico and swat in tampa well the
the the the difference was that each
each major city has its own uh swat team
and when i transferred to to puerto rico
there we were dealing mostly with uh
counter terrorism
[Music]
when i came to tampa
then it became uh
more
in the area of uh
criminal activity uh drug gangs uh
with a lot of firepower and so forth um
you know the puerto rico is is uh united
states commonwealth so we have
jurisdiction there but it's just a
matter of
the kind of work we were doing at the
time there's a really interesting story
where you talk about you quite
self-reflective to do with a challenge
that you had on the morning of quite a
big operation can you take us through
that
well
yeah it's uh
you know you you think back of all of
all the challenges and uh that one was
here in in tampa florida where
um
we were we were getting ready to to to
uh
do a swat operation and one of the
things that you always are thinking
about is is safety and have we
have we covered all the bases and
you know you go down the mental
checklist of where's the nearest
hospital in case somebody gets hurt
where can we land a helicopter or a
series of helicopters if somebody needs
to be medevaced you know it's it's the
kind of things that the uh the british
sas would would go through
and i noticed that in the meeting
um
[Music]
you know the questions that should have
been asked weren't being asked as as
quickly and and and and as
efficiently as as normal and one of the
things you want to do is is have an eye
on all the troops
who's having a tough time who's having a
bad day is anybody's mind off the game
just like in in sports
and finally
it just dawned on me even though i was
at the swat commander at the time i i
went to the uh the boss in the office
and i said i i got to take one of your
players out he's not doing well and he
you know we had full confidence in me
and he said yeah have at it
and i said well
that's me
i gotta take my myself out i am my mind
is not uh where it should be i'm not
responding to things i don't know what's
wrong and uh
and um
so you know i talked about that in um
in in in my uh in my book
and um
and i'm glad that i did it because the
the opera you know the number two guy
took over everything went down nobody
got hurt
but i had to be honest with myself and
have that conversation and say should i
be uh here doing this and it was kind of
humbling that all of a sudden
and i think it can happen to any of us
we can be physically not well we can be
mentally not well and that day i was not
mentally
well and then
um
i think a few days later i it finally
like you know you don't think about this
my grandmother had passed away
and um a few weeks earlier and i think
it was still bothering me and uh and it
affected me
and i think these are the kinds of
conversations that i that i talk about
in in the book that we need to have and
say do we really know ourselves
do we know our own weaknesses do we
recognize them and are we willing to
challenge
that and
and that's i think it's hard to do
because in an organization where you
have all these alpha males and alpha
females
and everybody's always gung-ho and and
willing to do anything and everything
um every once in a while you have to
deal with uh with the human factor and
uh
and
i i think that was good for me because i
think it made me a better uh a better
agent to deal with other people when
they had uh their own issues you must
have had a very good relationship with
your superior to be able to go and have
that conversation you must have felt
very comfortable with it
well we had worked
uh at that point we had worked uh uh
several years together and he had known
me uh before
and you develop confidence i mean every
every operation you run you run by them
and and you go through the list of what
we're going to do how we're going to do
it what happens for instance if they
open up and fire on us what happens if
they
take a hostage and and so forth
and so you you have that uh you have
that bond
um
[Music]
but you know it's it's not something
that's always automatic and
um and i was appreciative that he didn't
force me to i think a lot of bad um
supervisors would would have said well
you can do it get tough get in there and
just just do it
um
and he knew when to push he knew my
limits but he knew that something wasn't
right and um and and that's you know i i
talk about that also
that
one of the greatest attributes of a
great leader is the ability to observe
the the needs and the wants but also the
fears and concerns of the people they
lead and i and i think you know i look
back on history and and you look at the
great generals
and i think that's one of the things
that that stood out is that they had a
sense of
uh of each and every player and say well
this unit or this this man or woman can
do that
but we we mustn't push too far uh at
times
and um and and it goes to to to the
concept that to to lead you have to be
able to observe it's an interesting
thought that
it's not necessarily the thing that
you're running towards that you always
need to look out for it's the thing that
you're running away from like what is it
that the people that are working
underneath you really fear because
increase improving motivation or
increasing motivation might get more
output out of them but the thing which
is going to completely ruin the
operation is the fear
so getting that first seems to be the
priority
uh you nailed it chris
the
the the the thing that is never taught
in in any business school
in any management school is that you
have to identify that which
your everyone may
be may fear be concerned with and then
the leader's role is to ameliorate that
to diminish its capacity to to divert to
injure to hurt or to
um or to um
you know
cause people to to quiver
and that's one of the things that great
leaders do and and it doesn't matter
whether
you're talking about someone in in a
home situation with a small
group of five or six people in a in a
church or
or a military organization or as a as a
ceo
is how do you get through this dilemma
how do we attenuate
fear one of the things we're seeing
nowadays is we're seeing a lot of
leaders
who in fact inflame fear
who uh not only at times create a fear
but but flame you know um
um
create an atmosphere where it's allowed
to to be fertile and percolate to the
surface
not realizing that the greatest leaders
are always
ameliorating fear they're always pushing
it down
getting it out of the way because they
know that number one
fear can turn into hatred and fear can
be paralyzing
and
and so um you know whether you're
looking at the financial industry
in 2008 and you look at those people who
came forward
and uh and sort of helped us through
this and said we will deal with this
problem a little bit at a time but we
will deal with it while others were just
fanning the flames of uh the world's
gonna end
that's not leadership
that's the worst kind of leadership
how do you define self-mastery
that's a great question i think it's a
combination of things i think it's
number one
being in
being in charge of taking responsibility
for but also being in control of your
emotions
um
i you know i i looked at
so many historical examples and realize
that
oftentimes what has derailed
really smart people
is their inability to control their
emotions that um whether it was great uh
coaches or or uh
and any number of individuals uh great
military leaders they were derailed by
by their emotions
the second thing is
the ability to focus enough
on those things that are important to
you
so that you can then dedicate yourself
to that
you know i talk
about um joseph campbell in his great
book the power of myth and and you know
he
he famously said you know
you know follow your
your your bliss
and people
a lot of people made fun of that and
they misunderstood what that meant it
wasn't you were going to sit your
yourself down on a chair on a sunday on
a sunny beach and your bliss was going
to come to you
what he meant was
that if you pursue that which you seek
which if you focus on it
if you create the scaffolding
of experience reading
reaching out to people
that you can achieve that bliss
and that
doors will be open to you um i look at
the american example of
benjamin franklin who arrives in
philadelphia with 15 cents on his in his
pocket
learns the trade of publishing
uh becomes the you know postmaster
general of the united states creates the
first the fire department and then goes
on and becomes the first ambassador to
to france
how do you do that i mean what school do
you go to there's actually no school now
that you can attend to
that will teach you that
but what he did was he created the
scaffolding he
you know in in essence
he created that
whole apprenticeship program for himself
so that there would be no limits
none
if you go to france right now the only
statute there is of an american
is benjamin franklin
he wasn't president
you know he gifted to the world the uh
the lightning uh
arrester but but beyond that
you can create yourself into something
and that's mastery and it doesn't matter
whether you're jane goodall and you're
22 years old and you say you know what
i want to be an ethologist i'm going to
go to the jungle i don't have a degree
she didn't have a degree
she was a secretary she says you know
what i'm going to study primates
and became the premier mind in the world
in the subject of primates she's the
first to tell us hey not for nothing but
these little guys use tools
isn't that how we define mankind
it was it was it was a shock
she didn't let anything get in her way
that's what you can achieve when you
have self-mastery
so self-esteem
sorry self-mastery is a combination of
removing fear and then focusing intently
on the thing that you want to do it's
it's it's that it's creating it's
controlling your emotions but being able
to focus on the things that are
important to you and then creating a a
an apprenticeship program for for
yourself
10 years ago chris you weren't doing
this
you created this for yourself
you worked hard at it
you you you
you know i i'm sure you made plenty of
mistakes
but you got to where you are at
by creating this um by having that
proper scaffolding
one bit at a time nobody's nobody
said oh here's here's a memo follow it
and you'll you'll be
interviewing joe navarro or chris voss
or somebody else
you did that on you on your own and and
that's what the book is about
that exceptional individuals
they don't have to follow a a particular
regimen they can create their own
regimen and that is true self-mastery
yeah it's um it's a strange thing to
think about
permissionless apprenticeships as
they're called online
where somebody does just strike out on
their own let's say that there's someone
listening who thinks yeah i i know that
i'm ready to make a change i know that
i'm not in the place i want to be
how does someone set out on the first
step of an apprenticeship because i
think that's
probably going to be the hardest one
that's a that's a great question
you know experience teaches me that
you know it i think now it's actually a
lot easier um i
you know you can go on youtube
and and do everything from figure out
how to tune your car to to
to uh
swap out your uh your bathroom
appliances uh i i think it's so much
easier now when i started in the area of
non-verbals 1971 72 there were maybe one
or two books on on body language uh now
there's an infinite uh
an infinite number
so i think it's a matter of taking
advantage of what resources exist
uh but also re reaching out i i admire
people who
who re don't hesitate to reach out and
say hey i'm i'm starting out can can you
you know can you give me a few tips
just the other day i was talking to
somebody and and and i said
you've been working for the government
for 25 years you're going out on your
own here's here's a few tips number one
get yourself a nice business card don't
put too much information on it just your
name yeah email address
and uh and uh you know
and a phone number and that's it don't
don't label yourself as to what you will
do or not do number one number two if
you have a website don't don't uh
take good care of it and don't change
your email address every six months as
you go from aol to yahoo to
roadrunner and whatever
a little bit of advice very simple the
guy
came back to me later and he and he said
you're right
those those things were important
we can we can always find someone that
will help us
um and there's nothing wrong with with
uh reaching out to others and just ask
how did you do it
if i came to you and said chris how did
you do it you've got such a successful
program and i'm sure you could you could
say well you know the first thing you do
is you humble yourself and you say i
don't know what i'm doing but i'm going
to learn
and then and then make the sacrifices
one of the one of the things that i find
is people have grand ideas
but they don't know how to pay the price
they don't know how
to
so to focus to study
to
rehearse
to do things uh so that you become
better at it
um just the other day a student was
asking me you know well you know
i i find writing very difficult i find
writing very difficult
and
um i asked them well how many times did
you edit what you're working on and he
says oh i must have edited it two times
i go wow
i said do you know how many times i
re-edited my
complete book
that's 26 times
from start to finish
and
and it could probably
use even even more i said that's the
price that you know you have to pay
you say you know
you go to see a play hamilton wow
fantastic tickets are expensive yeah
they're expensive how many times did
they rehearse 47 times before anybody
saw them
and that's what most people aren't that
price is what people aren't willing to
pay
but
the swimmers that go out there and work
on their technique the the chalice that
goes out and perfects the technique
the person that like you
sits in front of the screen and and
evaluates themselves and says how can i
do this better
they're going to be the soonest winners
they're willing to pay the price
and
and that's part of mastery
and it's and it's
you know people say well it can be it
can't be done and my argument is it can
be done
the question is your dedication to that
one of the things that i learned a
couple of years ago that was so
interesting was the difference between
having a dream
that you like the idea of and having a
goal that you're prepared to achieve
so a lot a lot of people have the dream
of let's say being a rock star but they
don't actually like the idea of gigging
on the road or practicing playing guitar
and having calluses on their hands and
reading sheet music and having to go
through tons and tons of shitty
bandmates and deal with record deals and
deal with crap managers and sleep in a
van and do this it's like well hang on a
second you just said that you wanted to
be a rock star
like this is being that's what being a
rock star is it's all of that [ __ ] until
you finally get to play wembley arena or
somewhere in vegas that's that's the
price that you are paying for this and a
lot of the time i think
people would not put their hand in their
pocket and pay the price that they think
they would be prepared to pay for the
dreams that they have it's the ones
where you're actually able to get
reality to meet up with your pursuit
where you end up making progress
yeah yeah i think you're exactly right
we we want to be john lennon
right with with ten
number one hits on under our belt
you don't realize number one how many
songs he wrote that never made it you
don't realize how many songs they threw
away you don't realize the beatles
how much time they spent crossing the
channel going to germany playing in
these little clubs where
on a good night they would get 60 to 80
people
and uh you know they were being paid i
think
less than 60 dollars
in relative
dollars for uh for performing and they
were sleeping through three to a room
and uh and it's not a plus a pleasant
life
um
everything comes
at a price
um
but if if
if one thing instructed me and i'm sure
you read it uh you you saw the story in
in the book of this
this this woman who who does um this
needle work and i found her in brazil
and she's she was known all over south
america for her needle work and she was
blind
she was blind and she was doing needle
work and she had taught herself to
thread count
with her fingertips just like if you
would read braille
and she could read the material and then
i mean it was it was it was just
just being in her presence was uh was
was a wonderful experience
this is what she wanted to do this is
how she provided for her family and she
was the best
and um
and she didn't let anything get in
get in in her way um
but again is
what price are you are you willing to uh
to pay
observation is like your specialist
subject right so let's say that we've
got a beginner who's never looked at
nonverbals before what are the main
things that somebody should be looking
for
well you know obviously the the face is
the the one thing that we uh we always
uh
notice
um something so simple as you know when
we like someone we arch the eyebrows we
we
we say hey yeah that's uh right so we
emphasize with the eyes chris when when
you struggle with something your eyelids
come down and they stay down for a
little bit and that lets us know that uh
yeah you're struggling with with that
um
you know our lips tend to compress
when we're uh struggling with something
or we're in disagreement we purse our
lips forward
when we've made up our mind uh quite
often we don't do uh
draw shifting when we have doubts like
oh yeah right mate you know that sort of
thing
um there's just you know there's there's
there's so many things the the little
area between the eyes uh called the
glabella we furrow that when we don't
understand something or we're in
disbelief
there's all sorts of things about the
body but one of the things
for instance
the feet
are actually one of the most honest
parts of the body because
our feet don't have a contract so
socially if you smile i smile so there's
a social contract
almost everywhere in the world where if
chris smiles i have to smile back right
but your feet don't uh if if if you
don't like somebody often you'll see
them enter a room and they'll go hey how
are you but the feet are facing away
and uh we
the our limbic brain this more primitive
area of the brain that's really quite
exquisite
doesn't allow us to front
uh things that might be harmful to us so
we
do we turn it away you'll see it with
like little two-year-old kids they'll go
i don't want to talk to you
it's like well nobody taught them that
and yet they and yet they do it so
um
so th there's those uh those things are
um
you know uh you'll see the uh commissure
touching right so these are the
commissures of the mouth the corners
they'll go yeah
you know you know that there's an issue
there's a concern in in their their mind
so we we reveal a lot this obviously
this has nothing to do with deception we
we know that there's
no single behavior indicative of
deception
but it does give us clues as to
what the person may be thinking and uh
and that's always uh useful yeah what
about proximity from
someone that's a big issue because now
we know because of the pandemic that
people want more space
proxemics has more to do with
culture and personal preferences so
uh in latin america uh you know i come
from cuba and in cuba we stand very
close to each other we touch each other
a lot and so forth and then you go to
norway and sweden which i have been and
you know people stand further apart
there's less touching and and so forth
so um and that's a huge factor
when you're trying to establish
um
[Music]
a relationship
is if if you're constantly violating
somebody's space
then then basically you're making them
uncomfortable
and and that is is is not um
[Music]
that that just doesn't work
over the long run because all you can
think about is
come on buddy back up
um
you know i the the the brain is
the the brain in certain things is very
binary we're either comfortable or
uncomfortable if you get in an elevator
and somebody gets too close to us you
know we start ventilating we start
touching our neck we
we do all
all sorts of uh of things and it's the
same thing that happens when we're in an
argument
and uh after the argument is over that's
when you think of all the clever lines
you should have said but in the argument
you can't think of it because your brain
is dealing with the arguing
the emotions
and um
yeah so we
we we have to be mindful of of space
uh and even where we look at each other
right because you can look at somebody
so intensely that it makes them nervous
um women uh often complain that you know
men men have to be
reminded that stay up here you know
you're not you're not norad your radar
doesn't have to be all over the
landscape just right here guys
and uh
and and i agree i you know in fact the
research shows that um in in uh in a
social setting or a business setting it
really needs to stay uh just within this
this area
to make people uh
comfortable so yeah how can people
strengthen their powers of observation
then let's say it's someone that isn't
used to
paying this much attention
well i mean there's that's a that's a
great question it's one that i'm often
asked and i say well obviously
buy my books
and and uh and so forth but that's
that's just too easy
there's several things that i've done
over the years and one is
i obviously i've studied the literature
i've written
some of the literature but one of the
things that i personally do is i try to
watch films
from different uh cultures so uh big on
my list are from brazil uh korea
uh persian films i love
uh turkish films egyptian films and uh
and and films from from mexico
um and uh and eve and jan and and some
japanese films
and
and i when i watch them uh
to study the body language and to become
more focused on the little subtle
nuances
something so simple as greeting
behaviors
turn yielding behaviors
who can look at whom
um and validating that most of the
nonverbals that really matter are
universal i mean a smile is a smile uh a
nose wrinkle
right i mean i've seen that in japan
i've seen it in korea i've seen it in in
in in iran so
you know
um
so i i study it that way but there are
little tricks uh you can do
um so that can really help you one of
the ones that i use is uh every once in
a while when i go outside
i will
i'll i will sk i will do a quick scan
and say okay how many white cars how
many gray cars how many
red cars
and uh
and and sort of work my way through that
as i go through a parking lot as i'm
driving in and then as i'm walking away
to i'll say okay i was right there there
were two whites one gray uh one one
black
and like any skill observation is um
is a skill set that you have to work at
for two years while i was in puerto rico
uh they wanted me to be a supervisor and
i
it
it it didn't destroy but it certainly
hampered once i went off the desk and
was back on the street
uh i could immediately tell the
difference of how much slower i was at
observing
um
because i you know on a desk you you
look at
you know you're doing this all day out
there
you have to have situational awareness
you forget that you're supposed to scan
right you're supposed to scan uh
the the world around you not focus on
one little thing at a time so
training yourself to to do the quick
scan so you can read a whole room
uh is something that uh
that we teach and and you can become
better at it
you mentioned earlier on about emotions
and one of the elements that you
identify in good communication is the
primacy of emotions is that is that the
same as controlling your emotions that
what what's the goal that we're trying
to get through here that's that's a good
question let's differentiate from from a
um
from a biological
as well as a
evolutionary perspective
there had to be a quick efficient system
to protect us and that became our
emotional system
and i say that because
the the emotional system has actually
very little thinking going on so if
if all of a sudden i were to if we were
in the same room chris and and somebody
brought in a bengal tiger we would
probably
stand or sit very still
we would kind of like not move
we just can't do you see that beast well
yeah
just don't say anything right
this is your emotional brain
working
which says
in the face of fear in the face of a
threat frees
the freeze response kicks in people
think it's fight or flight it's not it's
freeze flight fight
and
so there's the primacy of of emotions if
if
if i walk by you and and throw a punch
well if you had to think about it you
know and say well you know i'm built
better than joe navarro my arm you know
i've got chris williamson has guns in
his arms joe's an old man you know
you're doing you're doing the math
i know you're having a visual you really
don't don't want a countenance uh
if we had evolved that way we'd we'd all
be dead we'd be thinking is is that a
friendly snake or is it ill-tempered
so our you know our brain is kind of
hectic
it it evolved to deal with the emotional
security stuff first and foremost
and that's why when we're stressed
we forget where the keys are and we
forget the clever lines because emotions
have primacy now having said that that
doesn't mean that we can't take control
of our emotions
what that means is when we have the
opportunity which is different when we
have the opportunity to reflect
to deal with emotional situations you
know you have a a child that does
something wrong
okay they're gonna do things wrong how
do i how do i deal with that rather than
fly off the handle that's the difference
where you have an opportunity to assess
the the emotions of the moment versus
something that's reactive
uh i mean if a car is coming at you
you're not going to be able to
think too much about that
that's where
and
and
you know
containing impulsiveness right there's a
lot of people that are impulsive i'm you
know you ask them well how much savings
do you have i haven't been able to save
any money
well yeah but you're spending more money
on your car then
so they're very impulsive with certain
things
and that's part of it too is is reining
yourself in and um
and and that's emotional mastery yeah
it's so
unfortunate that the high pressure
situations that we get ourselves into
are the ones where our physiology makes
our brains so ill prepared for it
so you do a big event you've got a big
talk coming up it's your first one a
lot's on the line you really really need
to nail this and then the night before
you don't sleep because you're terrified
and you wake up the next morning and
you're unprepared and you what's
happening in the body and the brain when
we're going through that sort of
pressure situation it's an awkward
conversation with a partner or a boss or
there's something that we're concerned
about what's happening to us
what's happening to us is is uh is
is you literally are it's an
electrochemical imbalance you are your
uh
your serotonin levels may be down you
you probably haven't been sleeping you
haven't been eating right so your sugar
levels are off um
your cortisol is flowing because you're
having this difficult conversation or
you're nervous or or you're tense
and
you know you
people forget the human brain is the
most complex thing in the universe
without question the the the the sun
that's easy to explain the human brain
we have no idea what's
what's going on we don't even know how
memories are really built you know
synapses are reaching out to axioms
you know all sorts of things
we
we respond to the world around us
um
and
and for the most part it it it's we have
a certain amount of control but it can
be overwhelming and i've been in this
situation oh my gosh you're gonna you do
your first ted talk
um how's that gonna
go over and
and and you worry
but then you start to think wait a
minute
this is where mastery comes in what do i
know
that
will anyone in the audience know as much
about this topic as i will
how many people have arrested a spy here
how many people have arrested seven or
eight spies how many people have
uh listened in on the conversations of
the mafia the the joe bonanno family in
new york how many people have uh
investigated 25 homicides in two years
and then you realize okay
okay start to settle down these people
haven't experienced what you've
experienced
you know it's well what if there's phds
in in the audience how many of them have
interviewed 13 000 people
you know then then you start to
to to say to yourself and everybody can
do this
what do i know how do i know it have i
rehearsed it
and then you can sort of
will yourself back up to where you
really belong because it's easy to crush
yourself and say oh my god there's going
to be 600 people there and these people
are my equals and they know stuff and
but um
[Music]
but yeah you can you can resuscitate
yourself
if you need to and sometimes
you know it's it's so overwhelming that
i i say
find a wall
and push it
just just push it
just push that wall
and one of the interesting things that
happens is that in the effort to push
that wall
that you're
forcing your muscles
to then send signals to the brain
which then begin to
create that homeostasis that that we
need because your brain can only handle
so many things and if you're sitting
there pushing just as hard as you can
your brain really can't do two things at
once
it's strange because we have the same
reaction uh innately when we stub our
toe
or you get kicked in the shin
because the reason that you rub it is
because the brain struggles to send the
sensation of both pain and rubbing at
the same time
exactly and and if you and if you get
kicked in one leg and then get kicked in
the other
trust me
i've played american football the first
one you forget about it's the second one
that takes over
it's the same technique that we teach
for instance people who
all of a sudden are having a panic
attack and you say squeeze the the nerve
that lies here
between the commissure of the index
finger and the thumb there's a
nerve there that if you squeeze it
really hard it's extremely
painful and all of a sudden if if you do
that for about 10 or 12 seconds and you
hold that
all of a sudden you find yourself
where's my anxiety where has that gone
my brain
is handling one thing at a time i had a
really interesting experience with this
so i came off a moped in bali because
i'm a awful tourist that can't ride
bikes
and
hit the deck grazed all one side of me
but because i'm a bro i decided that we
were going to go to the beach club in
any case and the lads that i was with
would clean me up when we were there so
we stopped in a pharmacy continued on to
the beach club as basically one entire
side of me is covered in blood uh and we
sat down and i had a beer and they were
like look right we'll we'll get started
with this so i had shoulder elbow knee
and top of foot uh and that was in order
of ascending extremity as well so it was
worse the foot was the worse than the
knee then so the guys were going through
it and they had alcohol swabs they had
iodine and then they had dressing so
we're gonna do all of this in the middle
of a beach club which was an experience
and um
you're right like
each time that they did it it was the
most painful thing that i'd ever felt
and yeah anyone that's listening that's
never had alcohol in an open wound
it is it it burst through the ceiling of
what i thought my nerves could
communicate i thought i understand what
pain is i understand the amount of
signals that a part of my body can send
to my brain
nah [ __ ] off this can go completely
through the ceiling so
it's like putting a cigarette out on
your skin dude it was it was insane so
he does the first one and i'm i'm like
this is i i can't believe how painful
this is and then he puts a bit of
dressing on and then the next one
happens and the first one stopped
i know it was it was kind of interesting
to see that sort of discrete pain
uh receptor going also the funniest part
of it whenever i look back the guy that
was doing it was being very kind i'd
ruined at least an hour of our day
because i'd come off this bike and he
was gonna have to spend his time as
opposed to speaking to the pretty girls
in the beach club he was gonna have to
clean me up um
as he was doing it he knew it was
hurting me and i was like gritting my
teeth and continuing to drink beer in
between it uh and all that he kept on
saying was i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm so
sorry and i was like yeah i know but you
have to do it so just keep on doing i
appreciate you doing this he's like yeah
i know but i'm just so sorry
inflicting pain on me in the middle of
this beach club um so yeah i see i see
that and the way that it happens another
thing there that got to a point that
when he did my foot which was basically
the entire top of my foot had come off
it was so painful that i started
laughing
i i that was that was the level of pain
that it got to i i burst out laughing it
it almost didn't hurt because i was like
this is
so painful it's ridiculous it's
absolutely obsessed absolutely insanity
totally totally absurd and um yeah for
some reason i started laughing which was
yeah
right that's interesting yeah by the way
i don't i don't uh uh i was also a medic
in the in the bureau don't don't put
alcohol on an open wound
dealing with people that were
riggers that had taken a first aid
course talking to someone that's never
taken any so they were they were doing
their best did you would you i just hear
you right say that you were part of the
team that surveilled the banana crime
family
yeah the one of the things that happens
in the bureau's you know we we we only
have so many agents so every once in a
while you're as i think you would say in
the
in the uk you would be seconded
to
uh another group and uh for about a year
i was uh i was loaned or seconded to
the group that was working on the joe
bonano and so here's all these made guys
who years later you would you would be
watching the sopranos and they said yeah
that's how they talked
you know they'd be yeah forget about it
which one was that how was that one
bugged was that the one in the house or
the one in the car oh the uh well
that one i i don't talk about in in in
the in the book what what what the
bonanno family was doing was
they were going to
this was a in the in the 80s so there
were still a pay phones so they would go
to pay phones around the city and they
would call uh each other using pay
phones thinking that the fbi wasn't
sophisticated uh
we had what's called a a roving
warrant
that uh basically uh we would uh
intercept
what was going on at at the main
junction of uh
a t or
whoever it was
and and then we would we would say okay
they're calling this number
and then the warrant applies to to this
uh phone number so they would they would
be sitting there with quarters dropping
quarters thinking oh this is really
small
and we're sitting there you know with
with recording equipment uh
uh
getting at all uh but i tell you what
you really learn about um about morality
and the lack thereof
i mean they're talking about either well
we either bribe the witness or we just
grab one of their family members and
torture them one i'm just like wow
it's like these people have no morals
they're just bothered with outcomes
that's all they cared about that's all
they cared about i mean there's a scene
in one of the
uh in a movie about the mafia where you
see these guys
uh
just for the sake of it they're trying
to take apart a parking meter which
probably has maybe
five dollars worth of quarters in it
and and it would they were relentless
and things like this it didn't matter as
long as it was an illegal way of getting
money they would spend hours on it not
realizing that if you value yourself at
let's say five dollars an hour
this is actually money coming out of
your pocket it it didn't matter to them
as long as it was illegal so they were
so seduced by
the idea of a criminal activity
that that's it it blinded them sometimes
to the actual outcomes that they were
getting from it that's interesting if if
they had opened a pizzeria they would
have probably made uh
you know
at a dollar a dollar 10 on a dollar
investment they'd be making money but
they didn't want to be legitimate for
them working was illegitimate
and uh and they would do anything to
to to work against it um yeah but but
interesting let's say that someone's
having a conversation with an
interlocutor and
it's getting a little bit heated or you
can't really get that other person to to
communicate in an effective way what are
some of the strategies that people could
use to improve their communication in
that situation to kind of de-escalate it
to bring it down and to start getting
everyone at the table again
are you gonna are you gonna try this at
one of the football games there and uh
that's not going to happen i work in a
lot of nightclubs though so i stand on
the front door of a lot of nightclubs
and very many times people say why am i
not coming in why it's because you don't
have any identification well i've got a
photo of it on my phone i'm sorry i
can't accept that blah blah blah blah
blah
this is such a
a big issue now because we seem to be
more intolerant we we seem to be lacking
the the social skills that we once had
one of the things that that i try to
tell people is that distance always
helps uh angling away
right
so
this is very intense but if you angle
away
if you can create some space
even something as subconscious as doing
a
artificial
cathartic exhale where you go
right
just doing that exhale lets the other
person uh know
at a subconscious level that things need
to calm down i i learned that trick
when i was going through uh paramedic
training at roosevelt roads naval
hospital in puerto rico
and the er doctor said
he didn't remember where he had learned
it he said but a lot of times you come
in
and the family members are all upset
because their
son or daughter is injured and he says i
just found that by exhaling
taking a deep breath and exhaling
then it somehow got other people to to
calm down and i've used it ever since i
didn't create this i
you know
but i've certainly used it and there's
something about that that that helps to
to calm things down the other thing is
that antagonizes us is too much eye
contact
so
reducing the eye contact so
as you said you're working at the front
door
uh maybe looking over the person or just
just around the nose area but not that
direct eye contact
um
[Music]
sometimes helps but uh you know
there are people who either have so much
alcohol in them or
um you know or they're just
really emotionally unstable
and you just have to be aware that there
are limits to what we can do you know to
the softer voice to the deeper voice
um
you know whether we say stop with our
fingers uh together or we spread them
out say no no no no no no no no slow
down
um it doesn't work that way
um there there's things we we we can do
sure it's a baptism of fire doing
de-escalation on the front door of a
nightclub the degree to which people's
rationality has been completely divorced
is
it's a sight to behold man like you know
girls girls tend to get
either indignant or hysterical um if
they've been the typical one is they've
had a bit too much to drink or they've
been caught inside doing something that
they shouldn't and they get brought out
by the door staff and the door staff
take them outside and say look that's
that's you for the night time you're not
coming back into this venue tonight and
what happens is the guys that stand on
the front doors for the door staff that
stand next to me and my boys um they're
the ones that deal with the yapping for
however long it is and yeah there tends
to be a bunch of different reactions
from guys it'll be
um usually
try and be give some sort of rational
explanation to try and appeal to the
rationality of the door staff and then
if that doesn't work it goes to insults
girls tend to
in my experience be
quite sort of indignant and can't
believe that it's happened and then it
turns into hysterics and this is
when people have had too much to drink
they're just so
there's nothing that you can say so you
know all of the all of the best ideas in
the world as you're talking about here
they they just simply go out of the
window there really isn't much that you
can do
yeah you're then you're really limited
um you know now you've you you've got
if you're lucky it's it's alcohol if if
you're
dealing with people that are
on some bizarre
homemade drug uh it can be really scary
because
sometimes they
they they present as having no fear they
don't mind escalating
uh are you basically i'm not talking to
a person anymore the the rules and the
procedures that you have in your head
aren't the game that that person is
playing anymore
well we we see that with you know with
with with these uh i guess the term
that's often used at these games these
hooligans who
i mean they just they're almost
reptilian they they they just want to
fight scratch hurt um
and and and they really have almost no
conscience and and i've seen it where
one one you know
eight hours earlier they were fine and
now
they're so inflamed that uh and and it
doesn't help that they're surrounded by
their buddies that are crowd mentality
crowd mentality plus a little bit of
inebriation is a hell of a drug hell of
a drug it's scary it can be uh be scary
um i i talked to a woman once who was uh
the door person she was uh we call him
the bouncer
and um
and she
uh
in fact i i talked to her not that long
ago but she had told me this story two
years ago
and she said yeah once they start
drinking it's a problem
but
you know i try to address it as early as
possible that
when i'm in that line
i don't wait till they're right in front
of me if i can begin to address things
while they're still further behind i
will say no
you know so and so
you know that you're barred from this
that don't even bother uh coming in so
she tries to address it as far out and
and she's not a
you know she's slight built woman but um
you know she's as we say she's a
tough as woodpecker lips
you don't want to
um
[Music]
you don't want to piss her off that
works really well so we have a doorman
doing what we call scanning so he'll
move up and down the queue a lot of our
events are for students and then
sometimes there'll just be a group of
guys on a stag party that are 40 years
old and the guy will just move down the
queue and we'll we will try and get them
before they get to the front because
when you're at the front there's it
almost feels like a stage so the
pressure's turned up a little bit and if
you have to turn people away there plus
they've wasted more time standing in the
queue which makes them predisposed to be
a bit pissy so yeah we um
we use that and it works it seems to
work really well talking about um having
someone
angle their body away i'm friends with a
guy called dr stu mcgill who's a
the world's expert in lower back pain
incredibly good physician unbelievable
uh and he
i went to go and see him in canada i
went to go and get an assessment off him
after i'd had him on the show and i went
and stayed with him and went fishing and
stuff and when he sat me down he gave me
like the full monty of his experience
when you do an assessment and the way
that he has his living room constructed
is he has a single chair a very nice
comfortable single chair and that's
where the client sits and then he has an
adjacent so forward and to the side he
has a couch so it's like an l but
there's no l on it and you're sat at the
foot of the l and he's sat on the
upright part and then directly opposite
where you're sat he's got a fireplace
and the fireplace is always on uh and he
was talking to me afterward and he'd
said that throughout all of his time as
a clinician testing and split testing
and trying to get people to open up
about their um imbalances in the way
that they move and stuff like that he
found that by having them sat looking
forward looking at the fireplace and him
just sat to one side still speaking to
them still facing them but not directly
facing them he found that that really
got people to open up uh it's
interesting that you have that same that
same insight as well
well i i would i would add even this uh
further um and i i agree with that
completely you know i
one of the things that i had to do was
to get people to confess to being spies
that's a tough job because all the
evidence is overseas right
and the and the russians
they weren't particularly keen on
helping us out so they're not going to
give us the evidence back so
um getting people to confess was uh
was not easy but what i found was that
um the most success
i had was not interviewing people in an
office setting or in an interview room
first of all most interview rooms aren't
designed by people who know anything
about interviewing so you see them
sitting across from each other
most most of the espionage interviews
that i did
without exception we're usually in hotel
rooms
that we rented for that purpose and we
always sat either
on a couch or a combination of couch and
chairs
but we never sat across from each other
we always sat at angles
and uh i was criticized a lot by a lot
of the old-timers
and you know they would say well just
bring them in and you know cinnamon
across from you and
you don't understand
yeah
you don't understand i'm i'm doing
interviews that will last
uh six seven hours
and
i don't and i want this person to to to
open up
and uh and that's and that's how i did
it
um
[Music]
i i understood as i'm sure your your
doctor friend understood that
too much eye contact affects
interviewing
that allowing the person to drift off to
be comfortable to
be reflective
is often better than um
you know than what you see on uh on
television
and um and i still teach that when i
teach interviewing i you know i i say
please do not sit directly in front it's
it's actually easier to resist someone
when they're in front of you
right you say no and i say no
you're telling me no you know it's
easier to fend somebody off than
somebody's next to you
somebody's next to you it's pretty tough
to
to argue with them it's like we're both
on the same side and that's what i tried
to create
that
uh you know look
the documents are already on the other
side that's that's already taken place
now how do we work our way through this
because the federal government's not
going to go away the fbi's not going
away
i'm not going away
and you're sitting next to me so
how do we how do we move forward and it
was always amazing to me how people are
willing to okay well
we somehow have to work our way through
this where if you put them in front
oh it's so much easier to resist
somebody
um yeah how can people become better at
small talk
that's tough for me because i'm actually
an introvert and uh
and i find you know groups um
a challenge
the easiest way is do not talk about
yourself i when when i'm at a party or
with a group i don't want to talk about
myself i know what i've done i really
don't
what i want to know is what do you do
what are you interested in
there's a park nearby here and sometimes
i i'll take the dog there and i want to
know what everybody does and i'm
fascinated that
one guy's an attorney but he's really
into photography
the other one is a grandmother and uh
and she's uh really interested into her
grandkids more than she is into her own
daughter
that's what i want to know about i want
to know about them i want i want to know
all the little things that they've found
what what movies they're watching and so
forth
i think it's really easy
um if if you can just at some point turn
it so that we're talking about them
um
[Music]
i think it's a little harder for me
because somebody will say oh this is joe
navarro he's a he's an author and
you know i i don't want to talk about
that i i really
i really want to talk about what other
people uh what if you came up against
someone who is another you though
because then you're going to ask them
questions about them and they're going
to go i don't want to talk about media i
want to know about you and your
illustrious history yeah so stalemate oh
yeah you have to have a backup plan and
that backup plan is i'll find one story
that i've told before and it's uh i i
consider it my giveaway and i said well
you know
one of the more interesting things was
this defector we were trying to get him
to defect and i and i sat down with him
and
um
we were going back and forth and he
didn't want to leave the he was on the
other side of the uh
warsaw pact um
i still can't
reveal what country he was in and we
were sitting there in a hotel room and
and finally i just grabbed his hand
he was an older gentleman and and i said
listen i understand completely i would
be scared too and
i don't know what drove me because i was
i think i was only
29 years old at the time i just
continued to hold his hand
and he began to cry
and uh
you know any and he said i
i can't continue to live this lie and um
and that's when he defected
it's a good story
that's a good way to start a
well yeah you know it's
it was something that was different it's
it's a story you know people think oh
you know you came through the door you
threw in a flashbang boom breacher in
boom send the dogs boom send the tear
gas in now we prance in and and hold on
yeah it's that that that's what spy
catching is all about is is uh is human
behavior um
yeah but you gotta you gotta be careful
with with your audience but i'll tell
you in the book you know you probably
read the story
um
where i'm in san francisco
and they're announcing on the radio who
just won the boston marathon and and
once again it was somebody i think from
uh
uh from kenya or
ethiopia or one of those great uh
runners from that were and the guy
driving it uh he says do you mind if i
listen i you know go ahead listen and
and he he says that he's he's from my
tribe and you know
and the rest of the day
as he drove me around
was listening to him talking about
how he grew up
um
in in that part of the world which i
so know so very little about
and then he revealed something that was
really eye-opening and to this day it's
one of the most worship conversations
that i ever had because i didn't talk
about you know i didn't say oh you know
i'm here in san francisco because i'm
going to give a big talk
i didn't want i wanted to listen to this
cab driver who then said the most
interesting thing i've ever heard and i
said why do so many
people from this part of the world
are such great runners and he said
something that
just
rattled me and he said we didn't we
didn't have newspapers or or magazines
or radios and i go what
you know i'm i'm figuring he's going to
say well we have great genetics and
you know we
we
our tribes were isolated and he said we
didn't know what world records were so
we just ran fast everywhere
think about that
we just ran until we dropped that
that's brilliant mate that's
that hits it right on the nail if you
don't know what the goal is if you don't
know that oh yeah you got to stop at 26
uh
miles
then then you'll run 30 and if you don't
know that
you're supposed to run at 98 percent
of your ability
you don't have a coach telling you slow
down on the first three-fourths of the
we just ran everywhere
wow
i saw a video not long ago of a school
child looked like perhaps kenya running
to school i think he must have missed
the bus if there was a bus and it's a
car driving driving behind him and the
kid must be maybe
11
or something 11 or 12.
and it's the most gorgeous running form
just absolutely beautiful turnover
speeds nice long rangey strides the
head's staying completely still the arms
are moving he's got his backpack on and
it's just go it's like when you see a
leopard go in slow motion it's just this
gorgeous running running style and you
just think that's that kid's 12.
probably never had an athletics coach in
his life it doesn't surprise me it
doesn't surprise me that they dominate
distance running at all and and
the temperatures and so on and so forth
and the long carbs and the good builds
perfect and and uh and running every day
and that's how he grew up he said we
just ran everywhere and and you think
about that i mean we get in a car to go
a mile to pick up the newspaper and and
and think about that you're right about
about their running styles they they
sort of
they maximize efficiency because
obviously if if everybody's running
every day you're going to model
whoever's the fastest and it turns out
when that when that head holds still and
it's the body that's fully gimbaled
you know just like a like a like a zebra
or a uh a uh a cheetah
but then you think oh man
what's going to happen the day we put
really good running shoes on this kid
and say the boston marathon
it's like over and over again
um
and
and they do it with such love and
appreciation for
for that um but but that's that's my
idea of small talk
my idea of small talk is to to listen to
what other people uh uh people say but i
have to tell you at the same time
um
nothing uh is is more painful than than
to listen
to listen to people brag
uh uh you know over and over about
themselves and i just
yeah i'm too old i just walk away
we've talked about being exceptional
today what would you do
how would you design a person
if you wanted to make someone as
unexceptional as possible what would be
the personality traits and the
characteristics and the world view that
someone would have that is the complete
antithesis of what you're trying to
achieve
not curious
a person that is completely not curious
about anything
not themselves
not the world around them that think
they know it all think it all
uh
and so forth
someone who is
rigid in their thinking
who is
uncompromising
who is unwilling to make any sacrifice
and wants everything handed to them
um
someone who
has no empathy
someone who
takes no action when action is needed
who has no concept of providing
comfort for others
i've never been asked this question
chris i think it's a profound way to ask
that question and i thank you for it
that is the antithesis and and and when
you when you say it that way
you think oh my gosh there are people
like that
and they're horrible
they they're so rigid in their thinking
they're unyielding they're not curious
at all they they don't want to know
anything about you they don't want to
explore the world around them everything
is
is so rigid and suspicious and and they
don't want to take any action
to uh to to help that is the antithesis
of um of the exceptional because the
exceptional really are about
um providing psychological comfort that
you know
they're about helping themselves
but not at the expense of others um they
want everybody to
to succeed they want everybody to have
fun to to enjoy life and
[Music]
and i think that's what really sets
exceptional people
apart
joe navarro ladies and gentlemen be
exceptional master the five traits that
set extraordinary people apart will be
linked in the show notes below and if
people want to check out what else you
do where should they go
uh please come to my website joe
navarro.net
and they can see all my books and videos
and uh soon they'll see my interview
with you chris exciting that obviously
the pinnacle of your career so far uh
joe thanks very much for
watching that i've dealt with i love
your your questions so thank you thank
you what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace